I feel it's my duty to bring the calls
between President Obama and president
Trump directly to you the American
people it's against a lot of released
private phone calls I don't care
here's the latest hello
Iraq I'm having second thoughts about
Betsy DeVos being Secretary of Education
how come I'm watching a YouTube video of
a horse that can catch the dead with the
truck
you can't nominate a horse to be
Secretary of Education no judge yet I'm
sending you the link so they say
personally authorized the hacking of the
DNC yeah
pretty serious stuff right so how should
I thank you
chuckling Jesus Christ I got a great
idea I am gonna build a bad-size
amplitude what between the White House
the truck down I'll crawl through it to
get to work every morning that's very
unrealistic you didn't let me finish get
bit at certain points in the tube there
will be three famous black
astrophysicist who talked about climate
change
Neil deGrasse Tyson and a kid what are
you consulting him about your energy
policies no I'm doing a crossword puzzle
back there couple of questions about the
White House
go ahead some blue what about it well is
that where I go what I'm sad
one more thing Situation Room
yeah yes does the guy from Jersey Shore
live there they're live there whereas it
was that room another Asian thing is
stressing me out
you had the odds stated Springsteen I
got no one how about stink said Oh
McCartney
no I don't know what to tell you Donald
maybe Flo the Progressive Insurance
lady's available
dad dad sure whatever Bell when you
decide what your daughter is the hottest
how do you break it to the everyone well
similar to that show The Bachelor I gave
a rose to the one I thought was a pretty
great idea actually we did of course
that's not what I did just terrible
killing me
[Applause]
you